all right moving on the men featured in
HBO's explosive new documentary leaving
neverland's say they expect backlash
after it airs Sunday in the film Wade
Robson and James safe Chuck claimed
Michael Jackson sexually abused them for
years Jackson repeatedly denied similar
allegations before his death in 2009
earlier this week the accusers told
Gayle King the film is not part of a
vendetta here is more from her interview
which you were seeing only on CBS this
morning you wanted to spend all of his
time with me out of all the kids in the
world he chose me he would call you his
best friend yeah did you feel like the
best friend too James
oh for sure it was it was very much you
and him sort of against the world before
I'd sat down with you I talked to a
child therapist who specializes in abuse
of children and she said kids your age
don't know that it's abuse there were
two kind of phases I see that when
you're young it's it is this sort of
loving tender relationship and activity
and then when I kind of got into puberty
when he started introducing pornography
and then you started introducing alcohol
the tone changes a bit when you hear a
Michael Jackson song you think what or
you do does it is it a trigger for you a
lot of times if I'm in a restaurant I'll
be tapping along to the song or I'll be
singing the melody and then I'll realize
what I'm doing and it kind of takes over
my whole body and I have to leave you
know he settled a case in 1993 and then
he went to trial in 2005 and Wade you
got on the stand and you testified in
his behalf in vehemently denied that any
sexual activity had taken place yes I
knew I was lying I knew that I had to
lie I when I was 11 first you know I
felt I had no other choice you know 22
what was your 22 you know it's so
complicated but as a combination of
still lots of fear wrapped up with shame
my whole life my whole career would fall
apart and then I wrapped up in shame he
always made me believe that I wanted
everything that we did sexually just as
much if not more than him right I was
seven years old and what is your
expectation of people's reaction to this
documentary are you worried or you were
afraid or you relieved I think it's all
of the above I expect people not to
believe there's a lot of threats better
thrown my way from what seems like angry
MJ fans I knew there'd be hate coming
towards us so I was expecting that my
goal was to connect with other abuse
survivors so I just tried to focus on
that the other thing about the
documentary the criticism I've heard is
that it's just one side it's just the
story of Wade and James and aren't there
two sides to every story I think we know
what their side is though they've been
very vocal about it they say it's all
about the money the family of the
lawyers right
they said that you all are just
out-and-out lying and that you're
opportunist for me and I believe for
James well I mean this is not sort of
like any Vendetta
piece and of course it's not good for
Michaels name or legacy but it's the
truth of what happened so difficult to
hear what what they recall from their
childhoods and Gale asked some really
really strong questions both them and
the Jackson family now Robson and safe
Chuck both sued the Jackson estate their
lawsuits were dismissed on a
technicality
they are now appealing that decision
believing Neverland air Sunday March 3rd
and Monday March 4th on HBO